c'est le tube du 8e tour de la coupe de
france saint-pryvé-saint-hilaire 4e
division élimine l'estac de troyes ligue
2 les pryvatains jour en les 32e de
finale et songe à une affiche de gala
[Musique]
recevoir le psg en 32e pourquoi pas mais
quelle que soit l'équipe
aujourd'hui on a fait quelque chose
d'historique le club avait jamais
éliminé un club de ligue 2 et voilà
encore une fois on essaye de faire
progresser ce club et cette équipe c'est
d'ailleurs le petit poucet qui fait
preuve de grande maturité dans ce match
les locaux ouvrent logiquement la marque
à quelques secondes de la mi temps
une ouverture lumineuse de vargas à
destination de fabrice seidou qui
provoque un premier accès de folie dans
le stade
elle est concentrée en sait que c'est
une bonne équipe
après on joue avec nos arguments on n'a
pas peur on fait on fait au mieux et on
se bagarre avec mon coeur et on espère
gagner
l'espoir devient tangible à l'heure de
jeu nordine benhari ce croise
parfaitement sentir
saint-pryvé-saint-hilaire a déjà un pied
en 32e de finale
l'unique véritable inquiétude intervient
à un quart d'heure du terme de la
rencontre après cette faute peu évidente
et un penalty transformé par jonathan
tient cette frayeur est de courte durée
six minutes plus tard ce match bascule
définitivement grâce à l'opportuniste
pape cei qui rêve pour pourquoi pas
aller jusqu'en finale
on peut rêver ça aussi c'est le foot
tout oppose arriver à tout moment
la réduction du score au bout du temps
additionnel calme à peine la joie des
banlieusards orléanais
saint-pryvé-saint-hilaire créer
l'exploit du 8e tour
[Applaudissements]